so stripping is different than dragged
and if you're showing kids stripping
that's another conversation and you know
the same thing well you can wear a dress
and not strip yes but drag performances
this is what the left is for instance
the left has been claiming that drag
it's not stripping they're taking their
clothes off on stage for a custom change
and it's like that's tripping yeah if
you're taking your clothes off it's
interesting they're just playing
semantics to manipulate to groom and
DeSantis is saying Eddie Izard he was
famous comedian still is that uh would
wear women's clothing he dressed and
drag for his comedy shows but he's just
straight up a dude no he's a guy no he's
full you're right Eddie Izard Eddie
Izzard is it it's full-on trans right
now oh really yeah yeah Eddie Izard for
like 20 years was just a dude that would
wear makeup and address and do comedy so
if a kid saw that I don't think there's
anything immoral about it it's just
Eddie expressing himself well this isn't
the only uh story that DeSantis Eddie
Izzard is gender fluid using the word
transgender uh
I don't know yep trans woman Eddie
izzard's been out as trans for a while
now